we're going into it yoshimitsu up
against kuni mitsu did they let the
intros rock oh it's the battle it's the
battle of the blade steve okay they're
fighting for the sword
fight tell me man
more matches are always good i love lore
matches i wanted that intro to rock bro
oop lol perry floor break you're going
to take it early
wall instead no no uh uh downstairs one
more time
and still gets the wall i was talking
about what she can do uh earlier with
the fact that she has
very good wall carry side step to get
the real line yukio in trouble another
floor break
oh tails for the back too the follow up
what did i say
dude and that wasn't even with the blue
stuff tries to go for the power crush in
between and it's not gonna work yukio
still got a chance spins the blue stuff
gets the wall splat
and the floor break we're going down to
the basement in the first round with 18
seconds left on the clock you can't take
you know the deal oh he tried to get the
174 pickup one wasn't able to do it
time for wasting and that whipped
the dowel back one whipped yeah that was
interesting that was actually very very
interesting
she has a very small uh hitbox like
that's why you have to be careful when
it comes to the range issues
and that full crouch mix up trying to
take advantage of it one more time with
the wild standing one i believe
dancing a little bit you can't let him
get a little life back dodge is the
kunai
dodge is the steak knife
dancing a little bit 35 seconds left on
the clock i understand yukio taking his
time especially considering
uh yoshimitsu versus kuni mitsu i feel
like it's kind of a mirror match of
sorts right very different characters
but they still have a bunch of similar
moves
so you could tell there was there's some
respect there especially on this wall
situation
no tech but finishes the string i
believe that was a counter hit two
rounds to none
in this loser's semifinal match oh yeah
nice counter confirmed there from el
negro
looking at uh how this is going for
ukiyo right now and uchu definitely has
to start turning things up here
again i feel like offensively uh el
negro definitely is in full control oh
my gosh the back turn launch
the stun so follow up here this is gonna
be a bad situation here he's gonna have
to guess
oh he misses
oh wow see this is exactly what i was
talking about
i think that like in this matchup you
have to play as yoshimitsu
a little more respectful like i think
you have to fight this match up a little
more respectfully
um like over the years we all know kuni
mitsu is kind of like a clone of
yoshimitsu right
and in tekken now i feel like they have
made it their point to kind of like
distance these characters from
themselves as clones
but kuni mitsu is a very unique case
because i feel like her wall carries
very good
she has like this true crouch mix-up
where she does start to get very
annoying
with that full crush down 4-3 i believe
it is in the 4-4-2
that gets scary you see el negro taking
full advantage
of not only that they're hitting but the
threat of it as well just going for a
while standing
in some of those instances after getting
like repeated hits on the mix-up
so i'm very interested to see what yuki
was going to do to kind of counteract
some of those matchups well something
else either you tighten things up
defensively to get out of the range of
things like of the from couch on 403
get out of the sweep range or you have
to go nuts it's one of the two
there there's no in between i think i
feel like he needs to start taking the
momentum away because
el niro is fully comfortable fully
comfortable going nuts with kuni mitsu
well i mean and still has more
characters like in the backup right so
if it gets too out of control
where el negro feels like he can't like
you know run it back could definitely
switch characters uh we've seen the
steve
we've seen the master raven today uh who
else have we we've seen the leroy which
actually got the w
so i feel like right now and el negro is
the person
who is a kind of leading in this set i
don't know if there's another character
on the side of yukio
but gonna have to turn it up a notch
with yoshimitsu if that's gonna be he's
magical
for life he's not gonna switch it's the
old boys ah
okay here we go match number two here el
negro looking very strong going into it
as well
100 match-up win rate for both of these
guys on the personal side
100 match-up win win rate on against for
both of them
against the respective characters i like
that if if there's one thing that i know
about yoshimitsu players their their
backup or their secondary character is
another outfit
they usually stick to yoshi all the way
i could do it too you're not the only
ninja on the crew
all right oh this time getting the crowd
chest right out of the r
laying on the ground respecting the tech
like i said you have to have some
awareness
of the characters that you're fighting
and these two oh gets the full launcher
no the drop you're gonna need those
yukio and now look at that just because
you missed that combo
el negro runs it back with the mix-ups
coming from kuni mitsu and this is
exactly what i was talking about
exactly what i was talking about
i'm just finding hit after hit right now
el negro working on the perfect we only
had
50 seconds left in the match el negro
finally gets a hit
the up 4-3
looking for a bunch of tech situations
and i feel like el negro is just
playing on the odds of him not knowing
he does not know what el nino is going
to do on wake up so just switching up
the options
puts yukio in trouble both
el negro on the verge of rage yukio
already in race getting hit by the long
distance kuna
and that's the scary thing that's not
afraid to throw it out either what's he
gonna do from far away
um and i think i think the idea maybe it
was a button mistake or maybe we're just
looking for another kunai
but here we go final round this is tough
he's going to have to react
well here and oh gosh very scary going
into it because again
oh like i said i missed that steve i
missed that so much
okay missed the knee he goes for the
throw follow-up nice break there
ukiyo nice didn't get the whiff punished
quick sidestep once again those walks
are starting to come in handy
el negro in trouble now two rounds into
the first game on this loser semi
let's get the break here try to get him
on the okie and that's good
it definitely looks like yukio is
getting a little more comfortable in
this matchup life lead with 20 seconds
left on the clock
goes for the low this time around and
the el negro not done small spin to get
out of the
mix up and down forward two to get the
launch speaking of two is gonna be
2-0 in this loser semi for el negro
yukio is in trouble on the verge of
being knocked out of this king of the
hill
that's fine it's a two hour oh it was
two out of three i thought once again
i'm thinking in fast forward
that's done el negro takes it over yukio
and man that was clean man that was
actually pretty clean
yeah so ukio now getting fourth place
here in this tournament
unfortunate for him but now el nino are
moving on to fight against